hi I'm Timmy the trashcan and I love
trash they all taste so good instead of
throwing your trash on the floor won't
you please give it to me thank you for
considering your fellow patrons welcome
to the Tim Dylan show everybody live
from the Tuscany Hotel a st. Giles our
st. Giles Hotel in New York City the
[__] Saint chills mean I don't know
that's what it says the Tuscany a st.
Giles hotel go st. Giles and I'm here
with Raymond come by secured this hotel
for two hundred and fifteen dollars a
night on hotel tonight which is not
advertised on the show no but it's good
it's a good service there's a lot of
amenities here
there's no amenities but the room is
large it's a nice spacious room it's got
a nice brown feel to it.try it's a [__]
steel yeah I mean when we came in here
before when you checked in we were here
for like a half an hour the spot to go
to that's like like she was waiting for
us in the closet it's made yeah I know I
won't clean now with like the you know
she was expecting a river of [__] yeah
you [__] him good
yes what is there [__] blood what do I
have to deal with right we checked in
and they were like I need his name Reza
I'm not flying over and the lady is like
yeah whatever you want to say say
whatever you want
he's not my daddy you go up you [__]
each other I don't care what you do I
need your name yes you see worse than us
yeah not much not much interesting hotel
empty restaurant downstairs nobody's
here it's uh it's a nice the steak house
is nice just empty it's a nice 5x5
double espressos in the lobby yeah you
know you're getting real nervous to like
this is about it's about to drop
I might cut someone in the lobby he's
doing some serious espresso drinking a
friend of mine sent their parents to my
show I did a brunch show at the stand at
4:00 p.m.
and these like you know high-end people
right Uppercross they make a world
though one they make it whoa
they got a little they got a couple of
shekels and they said to me the father
said to me because hey listen I love
these Jess you know one of them one of
the things that me and where I love is
the empty gesture and we always we
always fantasize about capitalizing on
it immediately and making the person
feel just like it because it would send
the person into a panic attack say go
into panic mode if you just on a dime
we're like y'all take you up on that so
he says to me goes listen if you ever
come back to New York just know that you
have a place to stay with us because we
got two empty rooms and I felt like
going great I canceled my hotel I'll get
my bed I'll see it the place you have a
car Mirai you're going there right now
now ray also needs to stay there and
listen minimum six months you can't ask
him to leave before six months you know
the bandages yeah he needs medical
attention
bring him into your home so me right so
it'd be funny if you showed up at their
house just fighting like drunk
just [__] pissing each other you
[__]
are we staying here or not
you said we could stay I'm just learning
[Music]
as soon as we walk in you turn around
the family we go I don't know about Jim
you keep an eye on him I think he's
trying to steal now I'll do what I can
to watch him but I need help
a place like that do you have little
things to steal they're worth money yeah
I mean would have the other rich better
than me I mean what we'd be looking for
a safe they've all knickknacks yeah what
porcelain knickknacks I mean I don't
think they have that I've been in there
I don't think there's any porcelain what
is the custom jewelry if you knock over
a place like that besides jewelry is a
silver word with money like what it
would depend on the type of people
sometimes
with some petty cash sometimes there's
some jewelry but I don't think there's a
ton of [__] in there particularly you
know that particular place I love that
we're talking about robbing what can we
get oh I just love the idea of that yeah
yeah yeah no you were good I'm gonna
come tonight I'm staying the night right
can steak too right they be like uh yeah
they would they go along with it right
they would go along with it yeah which
is hilarious why don't we play good all
you do is play the long game why don't
you ever play the short game play the
short game you're right get it get it
nice get us a little [__] smash and
grab
yeah what is this crazy as we are they
got even crazy like what if we walked in
drunk and we're like you want to [__]
and they're like Dewey clothes started
coming off with a strap-on then we'd
have to [__] them yeah I mean that would
be great if they called our Bluff I'm
like if they looked at us and they said
you can stay at the house but I'll tell
you one thing we're all [__] like
we're all playing chicken and we're like
well we're [__] neither one of us can
get hard they saw us hitting each other
would whip yeah friend of mine told me
crazy Epstein story about a family it
was connected to AB seeing the day he
died somebody on the Hamptons they ran
into their kitchen before the news broke
and they have like this big meeting and
kicked everybody out
well yeah I'm gonna have that friend
repeat it but I can't say it on the show
I also forget the name of the family and
I can't say it on warm-up it was warm
locker it was Warren Buffett I want to
play the new national answer minister of
this country by the way I want to play
this national anthem because you're a
lover of music Raymond I mean I make my
own music though you may know you're
making EDM yeah what this is an
interesting progression right because
you worked at a morgue yeah and then a
mosquito lab and now you edit from media
conglomerate don't forget the prison you
worked at a prison okay I figured more
covered that but you're right now how
did you become an EDM DJ well I've
always flirted with synthesizers and
making techno music I've come in and out
Miriam and I built the synthesizer when
I was in high school built sorta I mean
it was just like have like used parts
from RadioShack he built a synthesizer I
had voltage controlled oscillator it
made noises it wasn't a great scent
there wasn't like a real expensive yeah
you couldn't use it to make good music
but I was a handy guy and I was never
very good if I showed you my old tracks
they were terrible they were they were
unlistenable almost but you're really
proud of the new music your Mac I made a
big leap
yeah do not have the D I told you some
of them are pretty good if you were like
a young skinny white guy and you had
maybe the hot dark-skinned black
girlfriend sure you could do something
in the EDM community and you were young
and hey I think we could do a million
you ever was LA you know young boys you
know young guys very few of them are
from LA all right but we you know young
guys you know good-looking young guys or
so you're saying give them the EDM music
yeah and let that you be the puppet
master right like the who's the guy we
had that with the Backstreet Boys Lou
Pearlman who promised you'd be the
Pearlman for EDM DJ yeah who do you
think is a puppet master for this I want
to play this this is Dozier cat does
this on juicy so you know a very
talented young woman I feel like it's
just like him it really is more like say
something you white [__]
criticize me I mean like they really
calling the bluff here the people at
Juilliard have to be insane right like
the people's studying music have to be
mentally ill I don't know why I I mean I
tapped out of this [__] like years ago
but alright ai-ai-ai-aight allowed to
make a bit I mean did these like you you
you right you weren't the cardi B your
insurance fun I mean it can be fine your
interval is oh I mean this does nothing
for you um
well Liz owes talented she can sing sure
I mean what is the other thrown the dogs
or cats long juicy is it good good have
you never heard it no I don't know juicy
you've never heard juicy I might
approach a juicy I eat that lunch they
played at the Taco Bell okay it's catchy
it's better than the other one all right
that much well the other ones are
riffing maybe maybe maybe they'll become
a great song
I have no investment in any of that like
what is good and what isn't good right
you know I I just love the idea that
there is still a good right and that
there's still like I love the idea that
people are striving for to be good at
things I mean this climate is funny to
me that makes me laugh I feel like most
art nowadays
yeah literally just like the war of your
uncle of liminality the deep state what
everyone call it just shoving stuff in
your face going like this is a new week
like this is like it's just an act of
submission like submit to this my twink
is calling oh you want you up off this
that's it now
I'll take okay hi
why'd you say our [__]
I'm I'm podcasting that's alright your
anonymous say hello to Ray Ray is
podcasting hi how are you right not much
how you doing
he's chilling gets blunts garbage you
gotta get the harp lager yeah yeah can I
call you after we're done alright buddy
thank you he's not my tongue I don't own
him he's our twink right I don't want to
start being like that guy you rent them
I don't rent Raymond Raymond please
given how soon would be to politicians
start answering questions like that you
know we're gonna do
I mean I just love the idea that like
someone has to look at kids with a
straight face and go work hard gag get
great master your craft I mean how do
you do it well I mean what do you say to
kids now I sit my kids down I go son
it's a big casino right I don't know
play the air is gonna be toxic in 10
years yeah they're gonna get it they got
it like the way we look at boomers now
what do you think they're gonna think of
us what like our kids or a degeneration
there what did you call them when we
look at boomers boomer what did you say
huh
as I said burners boomers I said oh okay
they said burners like you've lit with
the Burning Man burners Burning Man
um I just think it's funny I'm having
fun with it you gotta have fun right
anyone obses tibet anything now you're
living in a terry gilliam film just
enjoy just enjoy the end and maybe it's
not yet I don't always want to be
negative it's the next thing if you're
like oh what do you what do you like why
would you have kids what are they gonna
do when the climate starts changing you
burn on the death who survive
figure it out our Boomer patch didn't
care was gonna they set his poison and
sent us out into the world with no
[__] money I think it'd be hilarious
if we did just keep telling them like no
it's a meritocracy yeah everything's
fine
repeat after me flippity flippity blah
right yeah have you ever had a business
I had business a failed business I was
doing a photography business
Ray Comfort ography the artwork of your
life beautiful sweet sixteens Bar
Mitzvahs do you know I think it failed
why is that because you're a talented
guy thank you but I think that you might
have lacked organization yes and I
wanted to tell you about something that
might help you in the future is called
Monday comm it's a team management tool
that will improve your office workflow
so they could have because I had a
problem where I wouldn't send people
within pictures right well this is the
thing right now many people expect that
right as they've paid you for their
photos right an integral either make
sure I make sure to get paid that night
what would happen you just go home and
[__] off whoa because I had I wanted to
edit the pictures and do it nice for him
right but I procrastinate and then you
know before you know it's the crease of
gone by and I'm trying I'm looking nice
but they want their Monday that camera
it makes it easy to track projects and
stay productive instead of email
spreadsheets random files whiteboards
to-do lists post-it note reminders
Monday comm organizers and tracks
everything in one place it's intuitive
takes no time to setup it's flexible it
can easily be customized it's easy to
stay organized and find files and it
creates accountability can I do anything
cuz I would also one of the other issues
is I would sweat a lot John the parties
and that would kind of turn people off
good would they have any kind of
solution for that
well here's here's what it is it is very
easily to schedule doctor's appointments
okay okay we could have seen a doctor
sure maybe address some of those issues
little bit being fat being fat being
disgusting right are being repulsive to
others sure now Monday calm streamlines
everything yeah you know what
streamlining us I'm not sure what
streamline it my shoes smelled so once
of that once yes I'm not sure a stream
of you
shoes off how do they even know so that
I had old shoe I have nice like dress
shoes right he's old like sneakers I got
caught in the rain ones so people about
Mitzvah once complained that my shoes
smelled well and it might have ruined
their day right but it's you reminding
tell me more about this so here's what
my day that calm down yeah Monday calm
streamlines everything so you basically
have all of your files mm-hmm your
appointments interesting well your
important calls everything is
streamlined irate emails irate emails
all these things but complaints about
your sent right all these things can be
stream I the only mature I don't smell
but my shoe smoke I try explaining that
to them
and they didn't seem to get the
distinction I think prize are not bathe
these are not sophisticated people right
right
so Monday comm basically it's suitable
for any size team from two freelancers
working together to thousands
collaborating across the globe did you
ever have a partner like a homeless
person or someone that you would take to
these events sometimes I would get yeah
like a friend to hold the light for me
great would I be able to use this to
form out to perhaps third world
countries people that edit the pictures
I don't see why not thousands working
across the globe that's that that you
know that works like a lack of leads the
tension here it's so effective right it
will put an end to long boring meetings
how many times were you sitting now
meeting for you cuz you're just working
on you sales meetings you're just eating
Domino's and sitting in your room and
write loves me I would meet people at a
pizza place in Long Island and you would
have to say I will photograph your
wedding right I'm showing it alive you
they had no right to complain I won't
either low rate they had no right to
complain it low rate there's nice nice
pictures in the low rate did you pay
them like how low was the ring I mean it
was a 300 I never shut the wedding and
that is low yeah you worked you shot oh
[Laughter]
they give me 12 14 hours okay yeah I
mean it's it's like but it's almost it's
like is it minimum wage it's almost
minimal that's not that much yeah I
think it's less I mean I'm all 12 it's a
route look 10 hours would be tell you
how to put the time in you go you got an
hour for 10 hours would be $100 so
you're you're paying yourself $30 an
hour
I do understand I had to build my book
where I needed better pictures to sell
more these jobs see the otega it's a
loss leader and you're working oh yeah I
was running around a wedding you're
sweating sweating just ibi how many
people during the bummers for a wedding
could you see were were visibly
disappointed with you the were enraged
well the kids were confused yeah but the
like the apparent level was like they
seemed to be like alright he's working
but the old beat that they were they
weren't about it there's no people were
angry they they were like what is this
what why like is you know because they
would not have spent they would they
wouldn't have hired me they were spent
real money but I think their kids maybe
weren't as successful or they're cheap I
don't know so point is they were
disapproving you want to know the good
news is yeah if you go to Monday comm so
there's Tim you're gonna get a free
14-day trial no commitment you could
check out Monday calm and see for
yourself how helpful their software is
one more time yeah I did not go over an
old woman once she okay she was to be
fair she was you know trying to get like
what they call a pin your pictures
you're trying stand behind me she was
trying to keep my pic like what do you
mean a policeman evening like photobomb
no like behind a picture like I got the
good angle can I know what I'm doing is
she also had a camera yeah oh yeah she
was trying to get my picture form it's
from Grandma who attacked her grandma no
I was just bad it's one of those
pictures of the cake and I'm backing up
and she's right behind me and she went
to the ground what happened when she
went to the ground was a lot were people
angry people smug Kim became and rapper
from your picture huh from the picture
we mean like when people run from the
picture to help her like the kid and the
mom and the mom ran over she still got
the picture I got before I knocked her
over
yeah I gotta get wasn't I had him come
back afterwards I just hurt not like it
was she didn't break anything then but
she might have like a look it's never
good when you're old to fall you can
always have like what was she angry with
you she was bewildered I think it she
was the husband was mad she was more
confused Monday comm slashed him 14-day
free trial when you went to collect
payment yeah was it brought up that you
knocked over woman I brought yeah it's
like how how is with that your mother I
don't know but that was that with that
lady okay and she's like it was very
current like she's fine
here's your mother and there was no tip
right did you usually get tips sometimes
I got tip what percentage of the time I
would say like 25% very low percentage
yeah Monday dot-com slash tip 14-day
free trial make sure that you use the
exact link because if you are using my
link it will be additional savings if
you choose to sign up thank you I mean
it is what it is man like I did this
podcast with log and Paul all these guys
were like I can't believe you're doing a
podcast with Logan Paul I I can't
believe you and Theo would talk to that
guy how about I hope you just roast them
I hope you're and I'm like no I'm gonna
ask him for a job dumb Fox the idea of
comics really killing YouTube stars
that's over what do you live in a
mansion yeah yeah what do you live it
and you could say to a guy like that hat
take your content socks to go yeah it's
not great they don't get like deep [__]
you people care but they don't care
that's why they're living in mansion
right the things that concern you don't
concern them that's why I just think
it's so funny that I'm gonna get up
there with my shitty [__] career and
start talking [__] to this guy right hey
buddy I'm the real deal I'm a comic I
perform a governess comedy club in Long
Island you're you [__] what do the
poles do I know they went to the suicide
farm and they they make city
right you chew like slumber party [__]
who knows right I don't really watch it
I don't find him in attract maybe we
could be the Paul brothers I would love
if we started it with a [__] for Stan or
whatever team 14-10 is Jake okay Logan
his low gang okay oh yeah the only thing
he's got low gang right he's fighting K
aside is black youtuber from the UK it's
a major event I'm selling at the Staples
Center or actually fighting a boxer oh
and they're selling out the Staples
Center in LA Hawking CBD oil on the
podcast and you want me to go [__] on
him what world are you and what own a
fantasy land
do you [__] people live in where are
you gonna really give it to him huh oh
hey who stopped doing that five years
before they went yeah no I'm going to
ask him for a job as a janitor at his
property as a gardener you know I hope
he takes pity on me under 10 guys in the
team 10
there were chicks and guys I don't let a
scholar of team death okay I'm not
saying first of all I want to tell
anyone this I'll talk to anyone on a
podcast
except their member of my own family
yeah we've been clear about that I don't
I'm not endorsing the content with the
kids I don't know what they do he was a
very nice kid sure he's not an idiot I
know everyone says he's an idiot because
I he's not a I don't know that I
wouldn't call him an intellectual I
wouldn't say he's a deep and
contemplative guy but what do I know
did you get that BA he's a lot smarter
than people think he is is you gonna
have I have people who meet with
Kissinger glyco or a president like you
could tell you he's got a Kissinger vibe
right that's exactly what he has that's
a good way nobody I remember when comics
used to ridicule YouTube people and
stand-up comics would ridicule the idea
of being a social media you know where
those people are now they're there
they're a month away from homelessness
they're performing in casinos they're
performing to half empty rooms of people
they are babbling about the craft of
comedy
in a podcast with nine listeners right
no one cares this is the reality
of course the poor brother just starts
Trump is the president what who's gonna
be a star okay I thought I still have a
chance maybe yes I've never doubted that
we should have had I look at some
good-looking guys and I go why you even
trying to be comedians just jump on a
bed in your underwear right they do
these things they're like let me do a
video about ten things girls do that
piss me off
that's what like they'll do that's what
a youtube star will do hit like these
are ten things five things of girls do
that I find really cute right five
things that girls using pissing off so
let's practice you're a YouTube star
yeah you're on your bed you're in your
undies get your shirt off and now I've
said to you all right tell me five
things girls do that you don't really
love they expect me to pay when I go out
to dinner you know they guys smile and
be kind of cute with it
you know they [__] are they look at
my dick all weird they get mad well kick
it hard I try get hard and they've got
to be baby's gotta lay there I'd like to
social media manager because they do
exist and that's like how these kids
would do a little bit then usually gay
man or clearly taking advantage of these
great documentary called draw a line on
Hulu about it where this gay guy just
has a house of twinks and he just orders
to make these videos oh but the manager
be like alright we're a that's good but
we you know the reality here's we want
to be a little more positive it's about
positivity
that's about people feeling good so even
though these are things that girls do
that make you mad we want them to feel
silly and light-hearted now we don't
want them to really feel depressed and
make people want to kill do you
understand what I was gonna take okay
these [__] well uncle oods to the
bagel store all right now let's not call
the Moors because a lot of kids parents
are monitoring the contact okay so we
don't want you to say they're [__]
right off the bat because someone might
a mother might be making dinner in the
other room they hear that coming out of
the back book now they're they're making
the daughter unsubscribe right yes you
see what I mean yeah we got to just come
in with it's a light touch okay kind of
a light touch many of these girls are in
their late teens and let's make no lie
okay fantasizing
about you sure of course five things it
grows to that kind of a queue in a cute
light way okay you know they asked me
what I do for a living I got like like
what what's your [__] dad do who the
[__] you say II think it better than me
okay that's not the worst thing okay I
think we could take the Fox out okay
here's here's an example of one that I
would do right okay like hey you know
like when a girl when a girl you know
it's one of the things girls do that
tick me off is like you know sometimes
like they pretend to like not want
something but they really want it and I
wish they would just come out like
really tell me what it is that they want
okay do you see that's more the
direction we're going at you know right
okay you got a watch to me doc Joline on
Hulu have you seen that you know that an
aspiring influencer who lives in
tennessee i talked about it on the last
episode and all of the girls that are
into these social media stars by the way
i thought these girls just wanted to get
[__]
yeah all these girls are like my
father's in jail my mother works three
jobs these social media guys are the
only people who tell me not to cut
myself oh my god are we in the dark god
are we in trouble like is this why
everyone went to go see the Beatles
is this where everybody went to go see
the Beatles on Ed said because they
weren't they were cutting themselves and
John Lennon was log don't call yourself
is that the only is that what it was
I mean look there there was a famous
head your song was like you don't have
to vomit to be a pretty girl is that
true no you don't have to vomit I mean
what do you think about these guns
what's gonna go on now we got mass
shooting after mass shooting after mass
shooting I made this point D who cares
I honestly think you want my honest
opinion yeah we stopped reporting on it
yeah we cover it up right I really do
feel I know it's like not worth the
anxiety and stress even though this
sounds like a crazy tank dude the
pushback
I got when I just asked a question right
how many massacres would it take for you
to adjust the ar-15 policy like how
would it be would one a day with three a
day I'm not saying I know what's gonna
work I'm saying as a theoretical
philosophical question how many they
would do it they look because they'll
come back with ar-15 with popular guns
in America and there's like five million
people or 15 million of them out there
or where they it's against sure whatever
but it's like the reality is people were
so much dumber than people give us
credit for we're so much more like just
animals yeah and like it's just
literally like oh this is on TV I agree
with a lot of libertarian ideas but it
doesn't work in a society where
everyone's [__] right everyone is
[__] and we're literally just
mimicking [__] Lee is right personality
populations but I think if you're
stopped people are listening to flippity
flippity boob bobbidi boo and we're
gonna give more guns I mean later
listening the [__] baby talk my
things and I'm being creative about it
right I wish they'd really like how are
you oh you're killing twenty people now
at a clip kill three but doing a [__]
way it stands out fine when the
Columbine kids came out but they were
new it wasn't it was a they were kind of
guys before the matrix even the matrix
kind of rip demo of it feels like it
like they were kind of setting a
standard with these trench coats and
everything I mean no one's got any style
anymore you know I mean why not just
have like yeah it sounds like an awful
take trench coat mafia out of fashion
stage right right no great point nobody
has an aesthetic yes
yes and it's just like yeah me and I'm
not saying like why not like kill a
couple people but do it in a crazy way
and there you go oh they'll give hey
we're like matching outfits yes do you
give any credence now we're gonna get
trouble but do you give any credence
when there's like reports of multiple
shooters and places and it's always just
one guy what is the deal with that yeah
because I watch people go oh yeah there
was multiple shooters or shooters here
the shooters there I saw I think look I
mean what's happening I think most
likely its people have no concept of how
most people have consummate how the
acoustics of gunshots work and then
there are people that say I saw a guy
just have full gear and it was not like
I mean hey look do you believe
here's a question do you think the see
like whoever the CIA whoever is just
doing me
for what purpose no I never said that I
don't say like were these people getting
their that like I don't know what's
going on I don't know what's going on I
think you're saying that but that is
usually the implication that it's a
false flag and that like this is done to
like I think it's a false flag I'm that
is it impossible that some of these kids
were went into some weird medical trial
that nobody knows about okay is it
impossible that some of these kids were
you know these guy don't know man you
know listen all the [__] that we've
talked about on this show you gonna tell
me it's completely impossible that did
[__] I'm just saying that's saying
they did here's what here's my new
podcast folks were no doubt room where
the tusky by st. John come kill us
please come we're asking nicely we're
asking nice we'll give you the room
number deep state wherever you are come
kill us I'm just saying like some of
these some super soldier program to get
to get people to like woke him again to
kill people like look at Vietnam
yeah just blow up like villages for no
real like no just give it off that's
where we lost that war and that's why we
had the drug I mean [__] I don't know
man I just I don't know what's out there
man I don't know how deep it goes I mean
I wonder when you look at the types of
black budget programs right the fact
that a lot of these shooters or a lot of
these homegrown terrorists a lot of them
have tried to get into the military and
then were rejected well they all
rejected or did they go into some other
program we don't know it's like the
party he's like he's trying gonna be a
cop and okay why don't you come in or a
little pro you know what do I know a
baby
I mean reality is like have you been a
Sandy Hook is my point I mean we should
do a live podcast of Sandy Hook I'm just
saying like I don't know what the
endgame is in the sense of like people
for years now for over a decade I've
been hearing and longer than that
probably agree yeah
that like oh they're just trying to get
into a position where they can finally
show their face and it's like I think
they're there I think they can show
their face then and the whole thing is
when it when I got people got mad at me
the other day because they said like hey
I don't know like you said that all of
the if we give up our guns the
government will really start to
overreach it's like guys that's not a
valid argument right because they've
been doing it already they just haven't
been doing it to people that look like
you yeah right
they've been going into all of these
countries and I mean they have been
doing it to people that look like you
because you know Chelsea Manning was
being tortured
oh sure Edward Snowden Barrett Brown
anybody was a whistleblower
anybody who leaked information that they
were spying on you and that the the US
military was committing war crimes he's
good I mean we've also acted look we
look the elites go to war because like
someone nationalized a banana plantation
over in Guatemala and like they've
economically decimated an entire country
yeah higher class of people and like
well we'll only fighting if they try to
take our guns away it's like wow like if
you know why not fight now I know these
are the protests in Hong Kong yeah
people getting tasers to the [__]
face over a like extradition treaty
right to magic we like extradition
treaty we don't what would it take
everything up murdered before he was
gonna drop a dime on politicians [__]
kids and nobody cares it's the most
heinous unimaginable evil and nobody
gives a [__] about it so my whole thing
is like well what would get what would
make you show up with the weapon I mean
if they came into your house and tried
to take your gun I guess that's the only
that's when you get up they want the
guns they're gonna fight the government
in case they take the guns right that's
the only time now we're let me do a
disclaimer yeah we are not telling you
now kind of way what's hard about this
is we kind of are
well we're with we're performance
artists right and this is performance
art I'm just imagining if they marched
on DC and said we want health care for
everyone right you can get behind that
man you're gonna go to DC and say we
would like a living
wait right or health insurance yeah well
we'd like if you not [__] again yeah
something but uh the only time I've ever
seen is those groups who go to statues
like this remember everyone was taking
down the Robert Lee statue called raises
statute yeah and so they go to defend
the statute are you taking these statues
down as you always ever see anyone do
anything with the guns wix.com how many
times folks have we talked about the
need to have a website but I've talked
about this so many times I'm so sick of
saying it
most people have given up on websites
they think everything's a social media
you're not gonna promote your business
on tick tock well maybe you will
but listen you need something more
professional than Instagram you don't
want your your professional content
right next to a photo of you eating a
hot dog okay you know Facebook is a
graveyard for boomers twitter is just a
war zone for the mentally ill Instagram
is for [__] food cats and [__] you
need a place to have all of your content
now did you have an alluring website
when you were a photo photographer well
I I did I do eyes on my own website and
I didn't there was no Wix there was no
you know these ladies
well it's if there was Wix the point is
I tried to either bake it I tried to
make it on my own with like just like
the programs used to make websites uh
and it was it wasn't good cuz yeah you
know like you I would put the pictures I
wanted to show on the website and these
women ended up looking fat because like
the pixel aspect ratio here right now
Wix is the best way to build websites
for your clients that you can harness
the latest web technology and innovative
design tools to deliver professional
results you start with a blank page and
designed the layout you want you can
grow your business with custom online
store out-of-the-box booking system and
live chat publishing a click and make
edits fast your clients will enjoy
enterprise-grade security and automatic
web hosting ok so get started on the
next client website today it's very easy
if you had Wix do you think it would
have been a successful photographer
oh absolutely cause like these people
complain like you know why these people
they don't even look normal they look
like they're there they're like they're
there they're no Photoshop them they
were also like I would try to sell
pictures but you know people people
be like hey can can you somebody's
picture on the web I'd like sending
through a Walmart like you know webpage
here yeah that's not good like oh you
buy pictures off Walmart I just send
them that lately your website is your
site still up I I stopped paying forward
so my business good website wasn't good
how long did you do photography well I
mean look this is my I eventually ended
up working for a DJ so he wrapped me up
under his umbrella of services and I met
you
yeah that's what I was good drive around
like some gang member well some of the
guys who work for the guy yeah they they
were affiliated with certain gangs and
which gang I don't know if I should say
but you know the Bloods the credit yeah
both of them I mean the first one okay I
mean I think it's so important to have a
good website and and I helped me you
know Wix uses industry-leading SEO
search engine optimization a powerful
marketing tool to drive traffic to their
sites dude that's what you got to do if
nobody knows where the site is or you
know then you're far no I would be
buried under like you know I'm trying to
like Google myself like Ray Comfort
ography and like you'd say Ray Comfort
Agra being still like you know this
third page on Google and like why is
that little Ray Comfort ography Shadow
Man before was even a thing yeah he
thought he was getting around ice you
smelled go to wix.com /g th one this
little one wix.com /g th one you need
the website folks you need it and if you
liked our show and you enjoy the show
that I do please support the show if you
need a website this is a great way to
support this you need so you can you
can't be having your business on the
same thing where you're bashing Trump or
support Ron Brown is separate you need
to clean you do need to keep it clean
you need a separate entity that listen
did you need a
delineation between the personal on the
professional that's a problem you you
should only let those things come
together when you can decide how much of
one bleeds into the other right most
people that are successful their
profiles are heavily edited if you don't
know who these people are look they
choose to let you in on what they want
veer garyvee type if your I had a guy
shoes by the way somebody sent me issue
you always read you always seem to be
tying them there always seems to be an
issue with they're not good their case
wishes you just dumb name on the tongue
I got another guy the guy thing they
with a uh
Gary Fong who used to sell we're
attachments for photography the most
this is one of my favorite things ever
he saw my sky I was like I spent $300 on
like the long island Gary V for
photographers yeah and Gary Fong I
bought this DVD set for $300 and he it
was me I mean look maybe I just wasn't
good enough to use his system but it was
a system have had to sell people on
wedding photography and hard there was
building these collages these collage
album because you know a typical you
give your grandparents wedding album
your parents wedding album it's a good
picture per page maybe a couple pictures
with the vignettes around them right no
you build these collages and Photoshop
any ideas you shut you charge right a
picture and you build these amazing
collages and then you know you give the
album you presented to them like the way
out of go I love this and I love it so
much you say well if you know here's the
price if you want to you know a little
much or you won't start taking pictures
out and what he's saying and then that
way I don't want to lose that one they
don't wanna lose that picture oh my god
I'm yeah I don't on the hook but I try
doing this and I was like yeah get rid
of some of these pictures was
immediately like I couldn't close salad
yeah I couldn't sell Gary Fong lose this
one this one I don't even know who this
guy is
that's some face of my kids basically
Gary Fong yeah wanted you to make a
collage of people's photos and hold them
hostage yes and sit down with people
yeah and upsell them yeah could
basically you tell me up look here's the
price of a baby could you say like oh
well yeah your album $300 album right
yeah so let's just say where that would
come then you go or well you know your
job well here's the album I designed
they also may
things always beautiful yeah well this
app is $1,200 and you know we want to
treat our album and you go okay you want
to take this picture out I think I just
picture your son will lose its will lose
your wife so you start destroying yeah
the album that you've made $1,200 album
he's telling you oh yeah yeah why you
look you got this they want you they
want to give you their money where is
fun from I mean Japanese maybe Chinese
amateur it's an interesting system but
he's like he's American like he's not
like a it's kind of a it's a fascinating
system is it's like but and like if you
get rid of them
I'll get rid of parents good nieces kids
epic 300 is five
yeah they don't give a [__] Gary Fong
that system doesn't work on the island
baby nah they'll be like whatever this I
tuned that is so funny so this this
thing that this that the so we'll do it
so I'm I have a son like thank you Ray
you did a great job we're very excited
to see the album yeah all right all
right so uh I took the liberty of uh you
ready see you ready already ready
already
I've the way you said I've taken the
liberty I'm on like big time got like
big time guard as soon you say I've
taken the liberty relax all right
you paid for your package came with
written our album and you're gonna get
that no matter what okay I'm excited let
me just show you what's available I take
a no Liberty
designing some more deluxe layouts for
you oh okay I can see you know your
option so watch take a look at this this
nice collage oh wow
I mean Lonnie look at that this is
beautiful these layouts this is really
nice picture the middle this is a 300 ha
look at what we got honey for three well
to be clear this is not the $300 Oh what
is this this is a hook this mic will
cost a little bit more now you have to
put you out like 400 will you'll you'll
have the option I'm scaling however you
want
I like adjust I like what you've done so
this album yeah we'll see same page this
one look it's adjustable this is quite
the 1200 jesus [__] christ
there's no good sir
I said he's gonna Gary Fong us I said
that's what these guys do if you want
the table she's heard horror stories
from her friends they all got [__] you
didn't pay for this down like 600 600
yeah look we can lose this picture your
wife we can get rid of this one she
doesn't look good now she looks fat okay
so honey pick the pictures where you
look fat um go to wix.com /g th one
wicks WI WI x.com /g th one don't get
fogged we had a weird interaction a tag
do you think explain what happened it on
the street cuz we've got a lot of weird
interactions in New York sure this was
one of the stranger wants oh the woman
by the deli oh now you gotta say that
just some woman with money and we
looking on any cash like just buy me
some China of some peanut my name's
right and then we did then she got
pistol this I think so it's just
whatever but though so we're working on
the street I forgot but yeah this is the
big one yeah so we're gonna Street
someone giving you and your spot
somebody gave me a book at the brunch
show at the stand and it's a book the
red dawn or some [__] some book about
whatever yeah it's a political thriller
British true it's Fick Nashik yeah so
this guy we're walking now and like he
and he kind of brushes past him and he
goes and he like sees the book of what
you've written here and I look a young
guy you know we guys in 30s like what
you reading there and you like oh
someone gave it to me it looks to cover
and I don't know if it's reflective of
the book he goes oh it's like a David
Goliath story this David wind and like
we're like what like and then he like
maybe she called me in the let me know
what happened attacked me the title yeah
and I was so thrown off I didn't even
know I didn't think the guy was trying
to [__] me I was so thrown off because
I'm so on guard for like an old-school
craft right smash-and-grab grab the
wallet sure grab my phone I take my
phone out he grabs my phone so it's
running now I got a chase this guy down
maybe he's a good runner right what am I
gonna do
but neither way he's better than you and
you all right so one five month day what
about now you're gonna check no we're
not chasing that No so I'm like um you
could just put and then he gave me this
long longing weird look yeah like he
wanted to [__] but what's weird is like
he didn't even see my face when he
stopped me wasn't a he starts it from
behind and present this guy except you
said I have a little bit of a gay walk
occasionally so from the back do you
think he said and that guy's I'm a weird
self from the back yeah if he just
watched me walk down the street that's
why you want to [__] me in her fat ass
no I got a nice face but I would think
you got to see me right from that I
don't think you were gay walking then
like a better no no but like you you
it's like you were just kind of
occasionally you have like a tippy toe
thing but this guy kind of thought he
was kind of look stunned that I wouldn't
give him my number and I think he like
walked her way and he was kind of
puzzled like I can't [__] that guy my
first assumption was it was a pickup
only because what else could it be
like it Grif but what is this grip baby
knows who I am and wants to put my phone
number on reddit or something as a joke
possible I mean that weights a dumb joke
I don't care yeah I really don't even
care so getting dick picks the girl
it's not bad people just call me I keep
on the phone for an hour they're like
this is a prank I want to go I'm like
now there's a super-soldier program I
don't know man but he was kind of
good-looking and I'm kind of mad dude if
I was that aggressive I get laid all the
time maybe that's just what that guy's
about yeah maybe he's just like he's
gonna [__] thick full of comb yeah and
he just wants to [__] everybody screwed
it up but also maybe wanted to come over
to my hotel room and like rob me sure
you know I don't worry but it's a weird
like what work on though I don't know I
don't yeah I don't get it like does it
with just certain dude just go hey
making me here yeah here's my number we
could text about this [__] if you pull
your phone he rips out your hand yeah
but he didn't even know I was gay he
didn't know anything about like he pulls
your phone out like and you're like oh I
guess I'll takes and like assuming the
he'll like you'll just not text him
buddy won't be polite and then he rips
the phone down your hand maybe I don't
know what the deal is I'm just kind of
weirdly on guard when somebody is some
stranger gets in your face and starts
asking you questions now I respect his
hustle sure whether he's snatching a
phone or trying to kidnap a kid or
trying to [__] try you know either way
I'm with you I just don't want to be the
victim of your scam right but maybe it
wasn't maybe he was just trying to [__]
I mean if that's the case he doesn't
think we're [__] good point
you know you should have stepped down
yeah you're [__] him he [__] me
I wonder he just gave me this deep look
right yeah I think you're crushing on
this guy did you he was kind of good
look but did you catch the way he looked
at me I'm like it was weird the whole
exchange very odd and I'm like kind of
paranoid cuz we talk about weird [__] on
the show I'm like sure is he the guy is
this the guy that's coming to get us
maybe he was casing us yes the guy Oh
Clayton guys is it Billy Eilish fan that
wants to be dead oh [__] he's gonna
torture and kill you I don't know nice I
mean I don't know but now I feel weird
about not giving him my number
not living dangerously I mean you did
[__] up I mean he could least gotten
laid or what did you think you said he
wasn't that good-looking now Hawaii was
bug-eye II wasn't your type you type of
Li like
yeah but though he was our he was
fine-looking I mean I think he was
definitely if you did that to a woman
listen what do you read wasn't that real
david-and-goliath sorry his David win
there's David win you want his tax ring
why don't you attach him in a title in
the book they would like they would use
like a patriot actually put me and get
mo they would she would use bear spray
on you not even may she go right to bear
spray she just takes to the gun just
starts firing wow she says fine
this is why we can't give up the gods
right you would be that a poster this is
why you can't give up the gun cuz this
man asked what you were reading right
what are you ready you want to check to
me you want to start a book club do you
ever think what would feel like eating
who's that Dickens you read it's out of
Tale of Two Cities isn't me I don't know
man very strange but I'll move on it's
another misconnection we're talking
before about you said you want to get
out of New York your point you you like
almost the idea of living in New Orleans
I mean New Orleans is my favorite city
think we're too old to kind of live in
us like I don't know I feel like I mean
I think we had our time and I squandered
all my time sure when I was 22 I
could've been getting hammered in New
Orleans I could have maybe went to
another country I could have went on
vacation dude oh I was just getting
[__] up in Long Island yeah what a
disaster what and I couldn't even get a
[__] TV show made about it I feel
like New Orleans is the kind of city
though words like you can have older
failures that are kind of not looked
down upon because they're not like don't
know money absolutely it's it's a whole
vibe yeah like you have to really get
into it we have to go to go for Mardi
Gras and like I think you'd have to go
there and just I don't I think the
charms would get old I think you'd have
to resign yourself to being what that
city is which is like kind of
disconnecting from the larger society
right which is like what
during larger society you're gonna miss
I don't know time sure makes New Orleans
like people have no concept of time
right them like they just float around
they barely know what they like well if
you live there are you going like oh you
even listening to jazz and like music
some people are I really don't know I
think a lot of people there there's a
literary idea of what a city is right
and then there's what a city is right
yeah and in my opinion New Orleans
probably gets the closest to the idea of
what it is from the limited amount of
time I spent there right
New York is heart disease a million New
York's there's a million Nell lays yeah
I mean the real la is the [__]
Hollywood everybody's trying to suck off
somebody famous whatever but literally
and figuratively but New Orleans is the
idea that it's got a very distinct
culture and that the people who live
there love it and want to live there and
they give themselves over entirely to
that they're not like they're new you're
not half in half out you know right
you're towing you go [__] head into
New Orleans or you don't even do it no
one really famous used to come out of
the world and something right now like
you look it might be someone whom left
new like New Orleans area but like who
what star got their start in New Orleans
like it's more like I can't think of
anything it's just kind of a place where
you just kind of live this artistic life
and then like you get hammered all the
time and all you living in artistic life
or you're just getting [__] up I guess
I guess you could be playing music woman
it's like a look was Hemingway like
Hemingway's writing these books and he's
just getting [__] up in Paris it's
like it's a cup but no one cares about
music or books anymore
like hey so it's just like we're not
gonna be happy anywhere good point
you know that's just we're gonna be fat
miserable where we go well why not there
it's a nice it's too humid
yeah the summer we're not built for the
summers you need a wiry guy who's not
built me as opposed by just so you wish
you were young and hot would you have
identify which I was young hot anywhere
if I could do it again I would do
nothing I did in this life right I
really believe that I would do nothing
and I know I make a lot of you laugh and
you got your dog funny hey shut up
if I
could do it again I don't know maybe I
would do what I'm doing now do you I
don't know I think I would do something
else
what would you be blank slate and then I
have some questions from the well no
we're gonna do them on a patreon episode
we're gonna record later in the week the
people the pay money get to ask you ask
questions and some of them are like so
stupid it's okay what do you think about
you know yeah and it's like alright well
we'll do that in the other episode I'd
be a lacrosse player is this true
I mean I feel like I would have been an
athlete like anybody if I can go back
like you could go back in time this is a
very fast anything afraid calm yeah
could do it all it can can I did go
through a period I was talking about
earlier where I write like when I was
around 30 years old I was running five
miles naughty when you were young when
you were 30 no I'm saying I was like 45
no that was like what seven years ago no
like something like six five I just love
the idea of like you're like listen when
I was learning my point is I'm not
running five moment run again where are
you running around the morgue everyone
around them work for a while and events
you want to go back to your glory days
of running around the mall I'm not
saying that but I'm saying it I came to
a realization like because it's fat my
whole life up until then there was a fat
kid was ever good I got like [__] and
like oh I should have been like pushing
my body more yeah I was a kid and I
would go back I would yeah I practiced I
know they're saying like understood they
say practice but until you get good at
anything
I've never good at stuff as a kid okay
finally if I get good at something
oh yeah just put the time in you can get
good at baseball feel good about
yourself like people like to pretend
like these you know that's what X don't
mean anything and their [__] like yeah
if you're doing two-a-days and at age 14
and like your whole town's revolve
around football and rape sure it's not
great but I mean the idea of having no
athletic background is a nice thing I
mean it's a nice the Greeks did let's be
honest there's no professional lacrosse
league I'm not you're saying you would
do some collegiate sport I'm saying I'm
talking about I would have wished I was
been more active and that would have
bled into the rest of my life okay I
would have probably got into like law I
could have been well I mean I could've a
trim lawyer she want to be like a fit
lawyer
no once I had a fat lawyer once I mean
the worst the worst is to have a fat
Lord because he was a good lawyer but he
was still embarrassing yes he's like
wearing like he's wearing a scarf in the
middle of court watch he was like he was
was he a real lawyer
no he was he really he's dead now but
he's a good-looking lawyer told me once
any young guy was kind of oh I did have
a different thing a good-looking lawyer
but he was terrible so the fact I was
good the fact that he's still
embarrassing when he gets up yeah he's
really he's good because he works he
wormed his way into the into the county
for years what was the biggest problem
with him was just the sight of him or
was the way he talked he was just
bombastic and he had a lisp in a slur
yeah I'm like but he was he knew
everyone it is used Christmas parties I
think we didn't fight the whole county
over like a flamboyant fat lawyer yeah
but he wasn't like at least no one
thought he was gay but he acted like a
pop yeah and he was crazy he was better
it was a real rock contour yeah and he
was good but like I was so like oh I
knew I knew he was right he telling me
like shave your beard like I look bad
with a beard you like your shave is I
don't listen to him now I agree with you
so you would be a fit lawyer yeah and
you would live where uh probably like
college would you go if you could've
went to a college where would you have
gone what's I mean I could have gone to
a college I think I'm a smart enough guy
okay are you pretty well in the SAT or
everyone about you everyone that knows
anything about you knows how very
incredibly intelligent you are and I
applied myself nothing I mean it's
almost like a 1280 but any practice was
not it's not
that's the charts off practice I'm
saying if I if I done a little bit I got
a 1400 right I think and and that yes it
ain't Mensa or that maybe this but the
point is like I could have been I could
have gotten into Columbia maybe or like
Dartmouth maybe I mean is that like I
don't know I don't know much about the
Ivy's but I could have gotten into when
I
now enough if you're a white guy well
you have it back dan mayo does a while
ago here's what I would say if I could
do it all over again I agree with you
Ben
lost his phone and this is how he lost
his phone Ben the producer of the show
yeah it fell out of his pocket playing
golf I mean I've never known you to die
I've never known you to put up with
things like that I mean I love my dad
but I mean is this the guy you know what
I mean else's wallet too I guess that
also did mm-hmm
is this where Peter says what does
Peter's upon this rock God says to Peter
upon this rock I build my church you
know whatever link off in the wallet
fell out I don't let you lose bow I mean
people change that sounds do people
change
another question the great ray come like
I'm not a trunk anymore right right but
I'm still like an 80 another thing you
don't still an addict in many ways you
white like it you'll change you just
white-knuckle with the rest of your life
you evolve I'm seeing attica I the
addict mentalities help me with comedy
you know like these people who find
serenity through Christ you write 12
steps they're insane yeah bless them but
that's a good insane you wanna be but
that's the best you can hope for look
we're right before about how like if
you're fat yeah like research that shows
I'll be fat and you lose a lot of weight
you keep all those fat cells the rest of
your life really yes the minute you
start eating fat again it comes it comes
right back
it's like that forever fat yeah so it's
like you can alter your behavior but you
don't change right and that's the scary
thing you're always gonna have these
demons probably I mean uh you know I'm
doing that key or trying to do keto it's
not real Aikido it's like he talks all
eat tomato sauce and [__] but I'm not
eating bread pasta rice sugar like you
know no desserts none of that [__] no
juice I'm drinking only water right and
you know I can't look up a good-looking
dudes I thought that we're really
good-looking dudes but if you told me
like hey you'll just [__] male models
for the rest of your life or whatever I
still kind of want ravioli that's not
deep the hook of satis right I still
kind of want ravioli till I've never
again I mean I want gyro that's the
thing what am i knocking of ravioli we
you know I want to zio I want that
feeling oh but everyone looking and they
want to [__] your or you'll have a
better chance [__] people yeah but
but I want lobster ravioli I mean do you
really want how much do you really wanna
[__] I wanna [__] decent man but not
crazy I'm saying he's people who [__]
all the time it's like I don't get it I
mean I have a girlfriend right lover you
know lose you know yeah everyone it's
consensual it's an eagle no need to call
the police don't file a report and we
and we have great sex but that's like
it's fun but I mean I don't want it to
be my it's sweaty it's it's a mess yeah
you don't want to be your whole life
right I mean I these guys where where
you going [__] boys I guess so I mean I
can't be a [__] boy well I think you're
putting limits on yourself and I hate to
see you do that but I don't know I just
you know I'm gonna try to keep this diet
going and I'm gonna try to exercise
right it's another thing I hate I don't
like I never known you besides the time
you told me you swam when you were
charged I love swimming I've never known
you to be like do any exercise have you
never just like you'd have a gym now
that man let's be honest yeah let's be
honest people get mad at this ready is a
controversial tank come on
is it exercise kind of for stupid people
come on
fundamentally I guess I don't mean that
it's not the right thing to do but come
on well they look all right era it's a
lot of dummies yeah anything is this you
gonna work if you're a working person
you gotta work now I know that I should
be stupid in shape but it's not my fault
right God made me you know I said I sit
around I think I think lay Eileen I I
dream you guys have much like how when
you go to work and then you go with Jim
you're spending like yeah when do you
actually watch the YouTube documentaries
when do you squeeze that time in these
people yeah I don't understand it like
how do you watch the docs yeah where
does that happen you could do it on the
treadmill you can do it on the
elliptical right I feel good when I work
out I like
swimming I should swim more I want to be
that guy again here's the thing like the
the reason most art is created is
because you don't feel good or content
right so it's like the point is are we
really are is anyone really the artist
anymore is art really exists at all
maybe not right and that's because
that's the thing like you gonna look at
Michelangelo i'ma go well he wasn't
happy but he you know sculpted you made
the Sistine chest he's not happy I get
the impression he hasn't your demons I
mean she had demons right uh pedophiles
yeah they were happy then when they were
[__] not all the time you know
everyone who's ever done anything great
was about what if aliens call our planet
planet pedophile and no one even knows
that aliens are like yes the most elite
people there [__] the children look like
wait well Chomsky used to love to have
the whole world of aliens came down and
they just observe their society what
would they think and you talk about like
well obviously the rich and all that
stuff and yeah you're right it would
just be like well you gotta [__] kids to
get ahead yeah that they would be like
this oh this is Planet pedophile yeah I
say left in their spaceship they'd be
like oh this is Planet pedophile right
that's what that is
but if I could do it all over again I'll
be a swimmer cuz you're the hottest with
the rip bodies yeah
dude I'd go to a state I go to school
like Colgate or Marist oh I didn't the
course can't be Colgate yeah I don't
[__] with the IV's
I wouldn't even make my life about
trying to be smart right or good like
this is what I've realized yeah I would
go to school it Colgate get a hot chick
or a hot whatever oh I'd be in the chest
probably you just you you would do a
scale a conversion camp no I mean we're
just doing a fake life okay and then I'd
have kids and I think I'd get like a
[__] house by a lake or something and
just not give a [__] I really think if I
could do it all over again yeah I would
be like [__] all of that I don't care
about I don't know I mean these kids who
grew up upstate well his friend was my
mother's friend was a swim coach at
Colgate yeah or Maris or one of them but
I think he worked at Colgate he ran a
camp there whatever and they had a nice
him his wife had a nice house on the
lake or his parents had a house on the
lake and you would go there and do
you know they just didn't give a [__] I
would love to have grown up a mention it
like yeah in upstate New York
oh man just a little bit of Tom Sawyer
like Italians you know yeah the food
sucks you have a burger who cares right
you don't need everything to be great it
ruins you I mean reason I like New York
just the food I'm a fat [__] yeah I mean
Cato I don't need to be here right I
don't need to be in LA I don't need to
be any of you dookied oh you do in the
woods in a raccoon that's the point [__]
you're gonna be here for right roast
chicken don't you just fantasize about
that life is just on the lake I used to
a Boy Scout camp that was on a pond I
don't even like the lake but I just the
life seems great the pond is not a pond
over lake is a nice it's an it's
Americana the oceans are great too but
there's something about a lake you have
a nice lake house is quiet you ever go
fishing what you write novels I'm I
would be writing a novel I've went
fishing you like fishing yeah but on
captain lose boat in Freeport with 40
other losers from Long Island right
calling the fish and words but no I
would fish with my uncle Michael out in
the Hamptons I like fishing we're just
like we're indoor kids only with
geniuses right the problem with genius
is in a society that doesn't care
I'm in the Tuscany by st. Giles Society
wants us to get in shape and go flipping
the ribbon in love and you know right I
guess we should I guess it's time I mean
who change your dye evolve or die yeah I
mean what both of just die I don't know
I like I take a lot I ponder a lot
during the day
you can't ponder in a gym right well
yeah I mean you kind of get into his
nose I'll lean on something for 45
minutes
yeah and sink no cuz mostly when I'm at
the gym I'm just in pain I'm just like
Oh what is hurting yeah I'm hurt yeah
and it just one at the end our bodies
have failed us our bodies our minds
matter
right or bodies which is why I'm excited
for the transhumanism put this mind in a
better body I love a spider barley I've
always wanted interacting yeah body
that'd be amazing
you're not going to us know your bodies
but like why not somebody why not
because it's not they're not gonna give
it to us we're not gonna get a good
spider behind really like maybe so
upgrade like something right we will get
the worst upgrade let me rusty it will
really be the footage of the same bodies
with like metal legs like Tin Man Tin
Man legs this is all you two got
approved for it's just like we have to
like move the spider legs with our arm
are we gonna get the new spider body no
you gotta prove to make your feet a
wagon we saw we still have to [__]
through the bug machine just alright
better better help is very controversial
add to do because many people online
believe there's a scam look and that the
people that are it's an online
counseling service and there are people
that have criticized me for continuing
to do the ad after they say it is quote
beyond a reasonable doubt has been
proven that it is a complete scam now I
do not know I don't think it's just but
I don't know look you don't know
somebody called me and said it would
work for them I mean yeah message me on
Instagram sure it was better helper
that's fine I mean I don't see why what
is dude real therapy's a scam yeah how
do you care the thing you got people a
lot of people depressed they eat bad
food they don't exercise the arm job
that you met all sorts of reasons you
know you're coming off drugs you're
going up on drugs
nah and what percentage does people have
health coverage middle few especially in
that sector look right if you have you
if you got a great job you got health
care you can still get the press but
less likely right right so all I'm
saying it may not be is it well this is
classes perhaps because I don't know if
you know it's great
is it better to
now we're out of time in your busy
schedule true health better help they
have licensed professional counselors
who specialize in issues like depression
stress anxiety relationships sleeping
anger family conflict self-esteem and
more now a lot of people have said
they're not if I'm gonna [__] gun in
my mouth right am I good I'm on the
verge it's [__] Saturday night take
the Chairman oh wait wait for a
appointment on pure high or recall you
gotta call better hold up I'm not saying
it's perfect
I don't know I've said listen if you
some people like to jerk off when
they're on the phone people yeah we'd
call them and you know what it was sure
no harm no foul
I can't see how it couldn't help at all
it'll help yeah a lot of people said to
me ah you can do more harm than good
just lot of people I a lot of people
people they're calling you kill yourself
a lot of well no one knows well they
should probably some people made a
pretty good argument that it can't well
but here's my thing with it I say hey
nothing ventured nothing gained right I
mean I'm not Raymond am I wrong it did
not said to me I can't believe you're
doing this ad how can someone who's not
a therapist convince you to kill
yourself interesting maybe that's their
logo
how can someone who's not a therapist
convince you to kill yourself nothing
ventured nothing gained better help
people have attacked me for this people
come up either very angry I do this and
it's probably the psychiatry industrial
complex I mean listen you know it's not
like a big keeping it around your door
I'm saying if you wanna have your
therapist you can request a new one at
any time no dishwasher
here's the other thing this what makes
unlike website that like the end of the
NRA back this is pretty bad you'll get
there buy more guns let's read let's
just let's just google them let's just
google them ready if you just google
better help because listen I I want to
be
fair to everybody okay and so so I think
so here's the thing YouTube one of the
most prominent sponsors better help was
caught in a world when a controversy and
we'll do it let's bow they've basically
said is that these are the real problems
here
okay so better help has said their Terms
of Service say we do not control the
quality of the counselor services and we
do not determine whether any counselor
is qualified with any concert is
qualified to provide any specific
service as well as whether the
counselors categories correctly or match
correctly to you
that's the Terms of Service but I think
they change that and now they have
they're doing a better screening process
to make the counselors better through
they did say that we while we may try to
do this a time to time in our sole
discretion to acknowledge it we do not
represent to verify do not guarantee the
verification the skills degree
disqualifications license certification
credentials competence or background of
any counselor look what does do like ask
you to send them a copy of your diploma
and then look at it I don't know I'm
still divided on this because on one
hand yeah they are saying that you're
essentially calling a stranger well that
you're expecting help you but on the
other hand isn't that life yes right
look that strange am I making a lot of
money in every situation sure look I
don't know man I I don't want to do an
ad for something that's a fraudulent but
better help is said yeah Derek Derek
finding better help look they're talking
to someone
someone's gonna answer I mean honestly
can we call them right now you look over
there hell yeah can we go better huh see
what the numbers look better help
somebody yo what you want suit
let's call better help pull better help
brighten escort circuits they don't
[__] answer well they don't seem to
have a phone number online that's not
great hold on you wanted to call Trudy
I'm sure it's in the ad I'm sure it's
fine listen folks we're gonna test it
out right now
better help calm slash Tim Dylan oh yeah
it's not a phone number you have to
probably use the app and there's like a
thing where you use the app - Cole yeah
I mean I'm gonna go to the site just to
see what the [__] they're waiting at the
riffraff like us you know the only one
people who are really really depressed
yeah they're there in chat video on
phone therapy yeah is it cost money
you know gender is male look at they
have they have their first thing is
individual counseling they go what is
your gender male female or non-binary
that's pretty cool yeah look hey that's
pretty cool huh select your age give me
people dignity I'm 34 select rage I
write 17 there right good what is your
orientation straight gay lesbian
bisexual not sure why is we doing this
how's that ice that's the next question
how's that is what what's all why is the
third question oh wait you like to sit
on why is the third question what is
your organization what are you wearing
I'll say gay but what does this have
anything to cuz this thing goes like
this
would you like to be transit or other
side
would you like to be transferred to our
sister site pride counseling dot-com
look they're catering it was micro
focused dude I'm gonna say cancel do you
consider yourself to be religious if I
say yes and they go do you want to get
Christian man oh
this whole thing's fake yeah do you
consider yourself to be religious yes
which religion you identify with
Christianity Islam Judaism what should I
say I mean Christianity probably well
maybe Jewish
she's supposed to be spiritual no have
you ever been in counseling I would kill
myself
yes dad have you ever been to counseling
therapy before yes are you currently
experienced a warm excited grief or
depression no one's the last time they
don't plan for suicide never experienced
a panic attack now I currently taking
medication now chronic pain no how would
you rate your current financial status
good I'm not trying to get yet how much
you're making you wait where's your
money bonds stuck oh yeah is it a liquid
how much you got liquid how do you rate
your car sleeping habits good who
referred you to better help let's say a
podcast which podcasts uh oh my god most
of these are just crazy podcasting
nobody listens let's say Tim Tim Dylan
sure what Tim bill is going to hell
next what country my in United States
which state am I in New York dude this
is [__] well they completed the
questionnaire now you got to create an
account first name Tim confirm email
that create password what should be the
password fraud she's my own pass the
noose around my neck
this is an interesting picture like help
me for the love of God how I miss
picturing like dad like he's like in the
garage Tammy come in you know Tammy he's
like the kid comes in he's got he's got
a new strands like go on better help see
cash word is too weak they didn't like
fraud
okay I'll choose another password they
didn't like that password I'm telling
you right now man I just want to make
sure that everybody that I'm not talking
something that's not good create a new
PIN what a PIN number for what though so
when you go back on this side they can
hopefully they're trying to get you use
your bank pin just trying to [__] get
your bank 172 okay so I'm gonna go on
this this code now one seven to submit
okay now I mean I should be in the site
right I mean sure the shrewdest Gherkin
prefer mail counts for female a male up
for mail next depression I'll just say
depression please no and if you
counseling I'll just write I'm sad
bigger like over that [__] well get a
better how what happens next how do I
talk to my counselor the messaging room
is available at any time you can also
schedule a weekly phone view so the
messaging room that's where you get your
target the cost is $65 you give you a
free bump no you don't give you a taste
folks listen I know people probably not
the best at but it's honest very honest
about with my audience um our job to
tell you is products out there it's out
there is that there's worse things yeah
right you could I mean it's better than
killing yourself problem with it is
better than killing yourself um so you
know listen better help get it yeah you
want it it's 65 a week hey you're an
adult you're an adult I love that you
gave straight dating website how's that
ass this the owners like yeah have you
ever used sexist therapy why have you
ever had sex your therapist in my head
person's like don't do this had this is
from an old ad agreement I had she was
like don't do this
oh really yeah but I always want to be
straightforward yeah with the people um
and after looking at better help yeah
and going through what I say we can
endorse it I mean it's there hey hey
it's there it seems to be your site it's
a site on the Internet
go into the messaging room and let him
know look he might have a nice [__] no
what if you just went in the message mom
just sent a photo of your right hand
would you [__] this I'm lonely what have
you just send up a photo of a bruise dad
say were you coming this yogami much I
just need some just a little the [__]
four questions ASL h6 location you know
better help go get him
alright thanks I mean it's hard I'm
trying to change man I've lost a few
pounds it's a table I'm gonna keep doing
it yeah I'm gonna keep doing it the next
step is I gotta start exercising but I
just I gotta get into it yeah I mean
exercising will get you kind of focused
uh I know you really mean you need to
become a jock I mean you could pick up
guys at gyms can you sure I mean that's
that's a more healthy way pick up guys
in the street apparently sure I mean
that's the thing you want to be a guy
who's got like just get some biceps
going get some next Oh wish I was rich
yeah I do wanna be rich dude I just want
up the you know just get a trainer to
come in and kill me [__] strangle you
I just wanted trainer to blow my brains
now I just wanted [__] to come in and
murder me so I don't have to go along
with the training program any which
would you just like would you do
fantasize about being crapple to death
by yeah I mean I don't know man III
we're at a point now where you go I'd
like to make something good for who for
what I mean that's a good point
who is your who wants it and I don't
want to be one of those guys who's like
[__] this and [__] that that you we
don't want to be that guy yeah but we
got to be honest and you go well well
you have his idea
like well the masses will go for this
but you're making something that will
last for history but like who's act like
almost like we're putting the time
capsule I'm waiting for someone to
appreciate it later on everything is
shifted we're even like the smart set
like [__] right the masses of always
like [__] the mass is now like like
gobbledygook baby talk right the mass is
like just big asses even even your
friends are talking over for your the
people came to your set yeah I don't
look around Amanda look I look at the
audience score they were saying oh right
like no one no one cares about Wi-Fi or
now if fine are I mean you think I'll
make some good for niche group is it
niche or niche niche I think you make
something for a niche group what and
they don't want it no I mean no one
wants it until you have that's all
[__] to rise like yes there is
objectively good art but you're rich
kiss jerking each other off right
exactly like you know I think what role
was a fraud we have now sure he's heads
and shoulders are better than flip at
the blah Blee Blee blah I think the best
life you just you have a lake house
you're cooking burgers on the lake you
reading your writing you're reading
you're swimming in the lake and you're
maybe doing a little light jog you you
know maybe go to the gym every now and
then you uh maybe you're the teacher at
the local school and the summer the kids
graduate you have sex with them right
when they graduate I come back as a pig
would you like to be a pig I'm feeling
it'd be a nice you know I'll be
slaughtered the first year but I mean I
feel like it this one I tell you got
slaughtered it would be good yeah I mean
look I don't think you have to come back
to be a pig you could pretty much you
could just climb in a pen yeah I mean
they're smart animals I feel like you
focusing on losing cuz you're big now
you're at a big place no yeah I mean a
book we we went to brunch today and
they're eating meat yeah I'm doing no
carb though I'm doing kedo stay stay
with no car yeah
it's the breads and the sugars man and
the rice is poison
not like you know reasonable people can
moderate themselves but I hate
we grew up with our parents of boomer
parents feeding us poison and we got to
a point where we really people don't
realize I was shot food-wise by the time
I was like nine I was just I mean the
garbage I was eating but I grew up on
garbage I grew up on fast food I grew up
going out to eat yeah I grew up at
Friday's I grew up you know and then you
get to a certain point where you've lost
control completely and now you got to do
a diet where you can't even have a
little bit of rice no look you have to
admit you're an addict the same way
alcohol and drugs and the whole country
we've got lots of addicts man yeah that
book that's the thing this country's
built on hooking you don't [__] yeah
it's just like you know use it before
like at like the [__] there's the
advertising firms with the cattle with
the cereals and the [__] and yeah and
the sugar cereals are just doing
anything they can to get it down you
know get it in front of a kid right so
they could get hooked young sugar
industries big it's just like what I
don't get is like so few people in this
country actually have like jobs that
matter anymore so service jobs it's like
there's like they're selling to us they
treating us like cattle to gets to buy
[__] but it's like it almost like
monkeys fake everything's fake like it's
not like why is it like if the elites
are really running this thing just to
like get get what out of us like I don't
understand it's like it robbing Peter to
pay Paul they're just they're just
cashing checks yeah just moving it
around just cashing checks dude
no that's the real creepy thing about
everything is like there really isn't an
elite like conniving and runt like
they're doing it they're scamming and
and you're killing people I think it's
out of chaos and I don't think people
like I don't think there's a grand
design this New World Order [__] but I
don't think there's any endgame this
depopulation of the earth or whatever
sure they would that would be nice do
you love that but I really think it's
just at the top I think it's just chaos
the reality is the economy is inflated
so like since like 400 400 years now
since this fed and all this stuff even
before that with inflation and just a
monetary policy and just expect
expansion and that that like it really
is a bunch of plates in the air and like
you look even if you were like you know
wanted to be Austrian economist
libertarian we're gonna solve everything
you couldn't even unravel it it's just
it's just a it's just a great unraveling
will be the final unravel yeah and it'll
take a long time right I mean somebody
made a point I forget who it was or that
Great Britain still called Great Britain
it takes a long time but yeah man and I
think if you read the Whitney web
articles about Epstein you see that like
criminals mmm and by the way and when I
say the word criminal I mean everybody
who's behaving in a legal fashion from
the from the government but to
intelligence agencies to legitimate
criminals to billionaires the crime
syndicate yeah and the many crimes that
are we don't like to say that we don't
have a shot right or to say that we're
gonna drain the swamp as Donald Trump
said yeah he can't even drain the swamp
we know about right there's a whole
other swamp that you can't even see and
no one's writing about it right and no
and the people that do get killed and
it's so much deeper and darker than
people realize and knowing about it
doesn't help and the only way to have a
good life is to not know yeah because
the only way you get in is to be
compromised right but it's the whole
thing with Skull and Bones we're like
were they they [__] blow each other
or whatever it is they do they do so
they have something all in each other
they don't trust you unless they have
something going right come on unless
you're unless you're someone we can you
know close the lid on we need to right
then you got getting then right as it
goes back to admire Lansky and before
any oh and [__] like you know
deterrent they boot like a
prohibition-era yeah early the early
mafia and people act like even people
who are into this [__] act like you know
as yeah the CIA used a mafia to kill
Kennedy but that's it like no they're
like there's a purse a permeable [__]
like wall the same way the finance in
the CIA is yeah
I mean you know so it's like I mean
Jacob Hoover is denying the Mafia
because they a dirt on it's an invisible
mechanism that controls a lot of what
you see right a lot of the stories in
the newspaper a lot of the things we
focus on are our distractions and then
there is this invisible all-powerful
somewhat omniscient right god-like
entity and that doesn't mean it's five
people in a room it means there's many
different groups of of criminals and and
the sophistication level is so high and
here's the problem
I am NOT defending the criminal networks
I run this country and I'm not saying it
couldn't be better
but when you look at there are people
who talk about the nature of democracy
and like democracy is unwieldy right
yeah especially on the scale of many
people we have and like whether we take
to do anything and it's kinda like would
you would they be able to I'm not saying
most of what they're doing isn't like
war profiteering right and like debt
slavery but like would they be able to
get anything done without using illicit
means you know under the table well I
think part of it is that we we all look
at it and know things aren't that bad in
this country because for a lot of people
they aren't number one number two were
pacified by a lot of creature comforts
oh yeah and things like that number
three I think the real horrors and
tragedies in this country we write off
as business as usual that's just life
right people are too sick they can't
afford the matter that's just life yeah
this person gets evicted from whatever
that's just life this old lady who's
been living in an apartment forever
gets evicted and yours they have a
health insurance what you want to wait
two days for a doctor but I mean so
we've conditioned the American poet John
conditioning people to accept nothing
right and to you know I did a joke on
the last podcast and people are
competing competing on American Ninja
Warrior for insulin and they're saying
it's a privilege yeah I mean that will
be what will happen down the road I mean
people love these GoFundMe you know
retweet the moment what a great story
this family had no money and this little
like there was one which was amazing
they go here's a three-year-old with a
disease john's healthcare company didn't
know if they covered a new wheelchair
for him so they made him a wheelchair
and home depot they like made him a
wheelchair and this was like tweeted out
and everyone was sharing it going this
is beautiful this is the American spirit
it's like no the American spirit is to
demand that the company give the [__]
kid a wheelchair right what but this is
the see babies fakin yeah oh we gave
every fake we're wheelchair we go out
business little fraud game in the system
but that's what I mean
we've been conditioned and you can't
talk to people right can't talk to him
about this because they all believe it
some overarching political philosophy
this can help it they've kind of lost
her humanity they act like they act like
we invented patriotism and weird where I
mean it's like freedom how about that
Trump article I st. where the people the
Walmart woman has no money and she goes
Trump made me believe in myself I
stopped paying Obama care and I didn't
pay the fine and nothing happened and he
taught me I could stand up for myself to
what to get to not have insurance yeah
what is we're rotten to the core rotten
to the core
we're not like rotten to the core it's
sad it's really well how does it get
better and it's all these people that
are positive do you not go outside have
you not had any experiences with the
human race here's a problem like because
of my ingenuity right or like presser
beer it's like no I think we could fix
all of this Ryan but like the people
just won't accept
I don't even come together no one even
like we used to value compromise yes
country and my guess Harley I'm not
saying the Republican Party isn't like
you know right and whatever but like
it's but there is the idea that you
don't know like come to the table and
make a deal it's just like you're a
traitor so the other thing is that
nobody that agrees with the problems are
right people don't even think they don't
think dick to know health care for the
kid is a problem yeah
they don't think the mass shootings
you're a problem they just think
it's a function of freedom and they look
at a decaying society and go out people
are free to do what they want to they
won't look we they don't want but I
didn't yeah you're right like they don't
want it to be better right we have we
want it better but like why that's a
great question why don't we want it
better that's a really good grab a nerd
wife at this point yeah we've just been
like sold
I mean look down deep do you think we
all want to like and I'm not saying
everyone's a pedophile but down deep do
you think part of the sickness in this
country is that everybody wants to be an
elite and everybody wants to be on
everyone wants to [__] people on an
island not saying I have to be kids but
everybody wants to be able to MIT murder
and maim and torture and kill and have
all this money and like is the it is
that just the dark you know have we like
is this country period that people say
that I don't think it's that I think
it's more fundamental that they just
think it's gross to take a handout even
though like they're taking a handout
probably you're probably like some like
you know middle class white guy are well
it was like on welfare and or whatever
like scamming the system but like the
idea of socialism is gross because like
just some look it's kind of like we're
in the middle of hyper normalization
we're the midst of it like when you see
year after year nothing change and like
you know Obama then before that it was
be a bush like nothing fun like when
Obama didn't shut down Gitmo and like
I'm not saying he was the same as george
w bush but it's like oh yes it's
business the more like over time that
just built up and so everyone's just
kind of like battered everyone no one
really expects anything to change
because it's just a swamp like what is
the swamp the swamp is is a vague term
for like I think the [__] us really
the swamp is that like the corporate
state right that you know whether it's
wet and however you envision that
whether it's lobbyist buying influence
whether it's the corrupt political
dynasty yeah yeah the FBI couldn't
arrest these people if they wanted
we saw out - well yeah I D like problem
that's good right here is my favorite
movie those conspiracy movies where they
go find a cop or something
he's in on it right you know what I mean
yeah every Stephen King novel you're
like oh that guy right but my point is
like but the idea that like it would be
hard if you actually had a
well-intentioned government to do
something about the swamp
I also totally understand people who
leave America where I can you sure ever
understand those people I don't say
people coming here we go bad yeah but I
never used to understand people that
would leave and now I'm like yeah I get
it goes from seaside town somewhere else
but I mean it's all getting bad there's
not a lot of places laughs I mean what's
gonna be funny is like even we fix this
we won't we've already poisoned the
earth it's done yeah I mean maybe it's
all fake
maybe so they roll rent Lambert I took
to a guy Hollywood he's like everyone
out his rent in Lamborghinis throw off a
to figure fee and make it yeah but no
they've made it yeah
that's up people justify I don't raise
kids there a lot of them are I don't
some of them have made it yeah some of
them have made it it is what it is
making in America I being a rich kid
being a rich kid is making it yeah maybe
that's if we could do it all over again
follow me rich [__] Lacrosse living by a
lake I just want to be rich I just wanna
have a a cold mother and an aloof father
and a lot of [__] money and
expectations my friend Michael
like one of my best friends has always
said if his parents pushed him a little
more
right cuz Kyle he got into st. John's
but if you could have just gone to a
little better college his life would
have been better
and he goes if his parents just pushed
him a little bit more not not that it
was their job to write but he said like
you know that's one of the things he
looks back on yes sounds nice but the
John Rockefeller dad with her deadbeat
so right hey [__] you Michael
Ray's right I mean yeah wasn't with the
Carnegie's that also like pushes shelf
we're comparing him
- the greatest some titans grabbing the
tire has never come from I didn't it
wasn't I never hear stories like my dad
which is like hard-working I know but we
can't that the big problem I think is
also that we talk about those guys and
that they're illustrative of anything
other than that they're freaks of nature
sure they're freaks of nature I mean
that's part of the thing that's like I
was joking around today about that the
motivational speakers Gary Vee well I'm
like nobody needs that Warren Buffett
doesn't wake up ago should I hustle
today should I grind nobody needs that
but there's a cottage industry of people
telling other people that there and on
the left or the progressives or whatever
you want to say this celebration of
people being 700-pound should stop yeah
I love women
celebration of women being 700 pounds
never men right so he's women being
being morbidly obese
no one knows as a victory no one knows
how to just speak without like hashtags
and like and like and then buzzwords
words like you know don't buy into like
the the patriarchal sense of beauty but
yeah don't don't be morbidly you know on
the bar on the brink of death right
there's no there's no nuance a middle
ground right there should be a little
bit of a middle ground I'm comfortable
with my body obviously not you out like
no one I'm telling we're fat I'm bad I'm
not comfortable it's not comfortable
this is not comfortable I'll tell you
another thing I just this idea that
you're good how you are and you should
never evolve or grow or change I mean
it's just the worst it's the worst thing
to tell anybody whether it's about your
body or your [__] mind
right oh you should just stay put stay
where you are I don't know man if I was
a conspiracy guy I would say that the
forces love this [__] sure they love
this pretend activism they love watching
a group of people just get too fat even
leave their house I mean we're gonna
fight right we're not are we gonna go
scoop up the UH the tear gas grenade
like the guys in Hong Kong and like put
into a thermos
impressive his Hong Kong Oh God I am so
impressed man day look I'm watching it
every [__] day dude they're Patriots
yeah I am so impressed that that even
exists in this country is [__]
laughable I do love how guys like he's
like right-wing people on yeah Twitter
when that will be like why don't you
left us learn something from that we're
like they're not the ones like yeah
behind like what you want them to write
do you really want us to let's not
[__] around you [__] [__] my
uncle said and he was quoting somebody
else once he said it you know I said it
right before Christmas prayer was a
little weird he said the country is too
dumb to be governed yeah too dumb to be
governed if it's not Trump it'll be
another con man and look at that's what
we get an8 it's not biological it's not
like Owen we're willfully dumb
we don't we don't like you don't have to
be your [__] Mensa student it gets
the food do you think part of it is the
point something help doesn't help but I
think it's more the iPhone it's more
like the TV and [__] was bad before the
iPhone it's bad it's gotten worse to
worse it's gotten worse
I'm saying it's when I say I thought I
don't mean literally the iPhone I mean
right I see amenities it's the creature
comforts that like the indulgences that
we allow us to distract us because like
you know no one the idea of like you
said before it was like you know we
talked about like you know how does it
affect me yeah and that that idea of
allowing it to like this connect where
it's just it is just as abstract aloof
no physical communities are dead right I
talked about that the other day physical
communities for the most part don't
exist many of them were built around a
plant or a company that shut down some
of them were built around a church
that's really no longer relevant to the
area and the only communities that are
left are kind of digital communities
yeah and you know I hate to say it but
they're not sustaining in any meaningful
way no I mean there's there is no
problem is they're so fickle yeah right
I don't really give a lot of credence to
religion and I think that you know while
tactics toxicity comes from it but when
they worked well when they were when
they were productive things it was like
it was a steady hand that you know it
gave people a sense of tradition
a sense of like you know we like the
idea that you like you'd grow up and you
teach your you kid that trade or
whatever back when we had more like you
know if you were Mason or a farmer or
rather like that maize Laxman yeah yeah
whatever was and like and and you lived
in a more like you know you lived in the
same town and the idea of like it's not
all just pop culture and thick like you
know I mean like there is that there's
no continuity honey there's nothing
timeless right how would you like it and
Donald Trump jr. you would always said a
very funny thing you had said a very
sloppy false flag in the Mall of America
you know Trump blaming it on China right
you see the video just fat guys the guys
Chinese blowing up yours Julius just
blowing up the Mall of America and
blaming it on China that would be great
I mean look that's I mean look I always
joke around a bride well 9/11 was like
blatant enough right we would look at it
mean the first day I only either one of
us was like a true sir right I mean it
was just like I mean to make folks
guards our sleeve it's goofy yeah it's
clumsy its goofy and it's almost fun
right it's on the edge of fun it
literally is like a chapel is the
Keystone Cops it's like [__] so yeah I
mean it's just gonna get more and more I
think they want to get to the point
where they don't want to work hard they
almost don't have to give us any type of
story anymore yeah I look now Soviet
Union when Chernobyl happened what were
they telling people when Chernobyl
happens like I was just like a fire I
mean yeah it was like they never try
hard ya know Gorbachev didn't have to
sell it just like hey you think we're
full of [__] alright yeah that's where
we're at yeah you don't like it [__] you
yeah how long have we done we're at 115
yeah we wrap it up it's a lot of fun I
should have given that guy my number man
look look yeah
we're gonna live dangerously what I mean
what am i protecting myself for exactly
you see yeah you got a little cub up
whatever you have you'll stab wound you
know I would here at the Tuscany Saint
cheales
Tuscany I mean the amenities were really
that's really well they have breakfast
in the morning I'll be nice that's
probably a lot of money but what am I
gonna do it is what it is I could walk
to the letelier's get some bacon bacon
and eggs yeah I don't know I kind of
want LOX
I want to go to Sables but that's all
the way uptown I love smoked fish you're
not that into it
it's nice look at last piece of LOX do
we have some boxes morning was nice has
nice lobster salad at tables yes you
know yeah key oh I gotta start going to
the gym I got to change at all yeah it's
doing the UH just sorta like walking the
treadmill maybe I can still get that
lake house get the [__] out of this
business I mean not that expensive so I
mean your house you can get a decent
lake house and load the Caroline this
may be one of those nice places laughter
is it all just overrun by like the Klan
I mean the Klan to be part of the game
there I mean like we think about these
you know all these out of touch people
like I just want to live in a small town
and they're like guys there's two of
those small towns where the rest of them
are bankrupt vacant lots where meth
Sambas are running around at people
delivering babies on the sidewalk it's
there's no sláinte small towns maybe it
was for moms but yep houses are 900
grand or that yes Oh Tim Dylan comedy
calm for any live dates I'm gonna be in
a lot of places I can't really remember
all of them I'm opening for Bert
Kreischer on his tour bodyshots world
tour I have other weekends coming up I'm
excited about them I don't know what
they are offhand but they're gonna be on
the website
Raycom you can find me on Twitter and
Instagram a trake hump or a YK UMP you
listen to the podcast also have a great
podcast with Lucy Steiner called our
love is disgusting both available
wherever you get podcasts yeah check
them out also if you want to contribute
to the show if you want an extra episode
each week and you want longer versions
and the desk videos we do if you want to
interact with us and suggest topic
the Tim Dylan Show patreon
get in there you could be a $5 men
member or you could be a Rothschilds
member $20 a month you get all kinds of
goodies it's more of coming for the
Rothschilds gonna do an extra episode a
month you get the longer versions of the
desk videos obviously everybody that is
a patron gets all the archives you know
it's fun so get in there enjoy that and
good luck and if somebody stops you in
the street just give me a number
give them your [__] number who cares
I could be [__] right now and not
talking about the demise of society you
know or maybe maybe that's what this guy
wants to talk about we that weirdo
that's the real that's to me off the
horror I show up and he's gonna suck my
dick I take my pants off because what
the [__] are you doing well talking
about universal basic income because I
talk about transhumanism what's going on
all right goodbye Fox
[Music]